welcome everybody another Google hangout
super excited to be here ah special
guest in the house today
xeno car the creator of the in spresso
song that's called mornings if you guys
are watching channel good morning
getting inspired I was some entrepreneur
knowledge and motivation you always hear
the in spresso song morning and I can't
tell you how many comments we get man
that song is still in my head I'm
listening to it all day long it's coming
back don't watch it and then I see the
comments and I'm like okay so this is
the man himself say no car welcome
aboard man thank you
thanks for having me awesome so for
people who you know it's the first time
on ER they don't know much about you yet
maybe tell the story of how how we
connected how this turned into a theme
song and let people know a little bit
more about you alright so basically how
it started it was oh I go on YouTube and
I just look for inspiration there's you
know I'm an artist so I try to look for
things that will inspire me to make some
more music or it helped me progress
whatever and then I ran across Evans
channel because he had the 10 steps to
success and so I was just watching and
watching and watching I really I really
like you know how you set up everything
and then on I noticed that you had a and
spresso like for every morning and I'm
like wait a minute I have a morning star
on my eye let me hit him up and see if
he'll like our song and maybe you know
he'll he'll like the song and put it on
there and have all the viewers jam to
the song you know every morning since
it's the morning song and then I reached
out to them and you know you reach back
so did you just send me eat now how did
that work you show me an email uh yes I
shot you an email I didn't think you
were gonna reply honestly I'm just like
you know is it's worth the shot cuz you
know you own the 10 steps to success a
lot of them is you know you just had to
take a shot so it's like that shot and
you know we are man here we are I love
it and it's funny yeah soon as I heard
that song like man that's a good track
was in my head the whole day like okay
we got a
a way to use that I love it so so tell
people a little bit about before we get
to like the question I mean you know
your path is an artist what you you know
what the kind of music you kind of make
what you want to do with your career
just give people a little bit more of a
background there
well basically with our music and I say
our because I work with another artist
named John Morano and basically he's
been there from the start like from the
journey and basically with our music our
musics like a new it's like a new genre
and it's almost like a genre plus a
movement and basically our genre
includes like all all genres in one like
it really doesn't matter what you listen
to you can listen to EDM trap rock
screamo wrap trap
it doesn't matter like it you can you
can tell everyone that you listen to us
and if you won't be like why do you
listen to them like they're hip-hop or
whatever you know because we combine
everything into one just to give
something that and we make clean music -
so everyone can listen to it and you
won't have to worry about anybody
telling you to turn it off because of
cuss words or anything I love it and
some morning has been your biggest song
to date is that right um it was until
recently when we dropped the I like that
video on elevator magazine that actually
picked up a lot because we had some
blogs talking about is here and there
and just a lot of people of just I don't
know a cause a lot of controversy
because a lot of people are like either
you really really like it or you don't
like it cuz the song is called I like
that so of course some people want to
say like that or you know just something
like that but I gotta go check it out
you got me all hyped up and I like the
morning song now I like that's better so
I guess I like that is is really high we
actually recorded that we shot that in
Atlanta in Midtown by a Piedmont Park
and that's a big part that we have here
and people have people were asking if we
had like green screens or done like we
literally shot it in the city they yeah
there for a minute morning was our
biggest song and uh morning was our
biggest song because for that one we had
actually gathered fan
and videos because at first oh we had
dropped a song this was when I was in
high school last year before I graduated
everybody was sending us fan videos and
stuff like that's really you know what
we're gonna save these videos and then I
don't know what we're gonna do with them
later and and then actually a time came
and then we just put him all in our
music video and then you'll see that at
the end if you haven't nice well both
around my list both on my list of to
dues man I'm excited tell me about how
did you get the magazine opportunity
like there's a lot of entrepreneur 'test
like trying to get their their art to
get exposed how did that the opportunity
with I like that come across where you
got into the magazine oh basically um no
he reached he reached out to us because
uh usually the music bet that he used
the gifts in the music that people
submit to him is all like rat bass and
so like they're talking about drugs you
know other stuff like that and then here
we come and he comes across us and then
we're not talking about any of that and
our music doesn't sound like anybody
else's our music sounds like everybody
use except is clean music and so he he
hit his back leg yo I really like what
you guys are doing you guys really you
know made my day fun for looking at
music and he was listening to our music
and he actually wrote a post about it's
like a little blog and you can actually
check that out on elevator magazine if
you just type in Santo car and then
elevator magazine on Google cool now why
why clean why was that important to you
that it's clean music um clean music it
really wasn't like alright I'm gonna do
clean me this is I don't I don't know
like I never felt the need to put
anything bad in it from the start and
plus I knew it I knew my parents were
gonna be listening to it and stuff like
that I don't want to show them and then
it be like uh
Yeah right here but on and plus it's
just it's just the movement and plus you
can get farther with it just because
they can play in stores and everything
they won't have to worry about we can
send it to the radio and they won't have
to worry about re send us a radio edit
and it was you know just all that it
just cuts down on problems and plus I
don't know I don't really know how to
write with like cuss words and stuff
like that like I never started doing it
cuz people are like always it's hard to
write without cuss words I'm just like I
mean I don't know it's just what you're
used to basically mmm is interesting cuz
on my channel whenever somebody's
swearing we always kind of bleep it out
and and some people like that and some
people give us a lot of crap for but
it's just like personal philosophy man
you just want to keep everything family
friend because if you keep everything
family for anyone can listen to it and
everyone can jam out to it so how do you
how do you like you got a partner in
this how do you guys break up the the
responsibilities who does what um
basically I'm a singer and music
producer and Zamorano he's a melodies so
basically what that is is it's a new
it's a new term that we made up but
really it's not really it's just he's
not a rapper but he like you can hear
every note that he hits his on and it's
like he makes it like really good
melodies so basically what we do is um
we'll be we'll be in the studio and then
actually ROYGBIV that was made in like a
week and a half every day we would we
would sit down and would be like alright
we need to make something new and then
we would start from scratch and then
basically what that consisted of was I
will make the beat on a spot we will
write the lyrics on the spot actually I
like that it was one of those two where
we made the beat on a spot I wrote the
lyrics on a spot mixed it mastered it
and released it on the spot in one day
and that happened for like a week and a
half straight of just every day will
make something new and we had to be on
top of it because we're just like
alright we don't want anybody to have a
song on there
everybody's just like I don't like the
quality or anything so it was a lot of
pressure on us just to push everything
out like that because we didn't have
anything out like projects before that
so is that your is that your creative
process is it just like you get together
and just jam and and wait for something
to come out or do you like how do you
how do you come up with these these
songs well really what makes what makes
us different is um we just all right
we'll sit we'll sit down and then I'll
be I'll be making something and then
what like we'll just be talking about
have a good time because most of people
nowadays they're not they're just making
music just to make music all right I'll
make it with this music or whatever like
for us like it's really like a passion
that we're just like all right we're
gonna have fun with a like we're gonna
add goofy on the Mikey no we're just
laughing stuff like that and then at the
end of the time it just works out and
then like really our stuff we're just
laughing the whole time like the whole
time we're just dying we're like alright
we're gonna put this in the track just
because we don't know what people are
gonna think but it's funny to us so
we're just gonna fool everybody we're
just gonna put that out and this let
everybody else laugh to it or whatever
cuz people a lot of people think what
they're like all you take any series
isn't that yeah we're taking a series
but it's just you know you got to learn
to have fun with it and that's that's
what a lot of people aren't doing
nowadays or just cleaning it out just
because everyone else is doing it
basically but ours that's why our stuff
sounds different because we have a
different vibe when we're making it cool
man and then do you have goals for like
number of songs you want to make or is
it just whenever the time kind of feels
right you get in and you just start
recording how does that work um there's
not there's not really like a goal on
like how many because our whole thing is
a quality over quantity because yeah we
yeah we could come in here every day
every day have a hundred songs but if we
have a hundred songs and they all sound
the same then I don't really feel like
we're working we're not progressing
because our our whole thing is
progression and every song we try to you
know I try to get my mixing better
because I'm not really an engineer like
that but it sounds the songs sound
pretty official even though like we
don't like her for as a morano's take we
went to a studio for that one but for
our tape words you Biff that was
actually record
housed at this cool man I love I love
the bootstrapping
no man that's how you start whoo-hoo-hoo
in the music industry is are your
mentors would you say like people you
look up to aspire to be like have that
kind of impact who who do you who looked
up look Wow who do you look up to in the
industry um really when it was it was a
few years back really when I just first
started doing music production like I
would I would look up to people but then
I noticed like as as I was going I was
progression like some people started
falling off like they started getting
less and less recognition and stuff like
that so at the end like I had to stop
like look into them because I'm like I
don't want to end up like them because
you know they're not really getting that
much recognition like my whole thing I'm
trying to stay on the top every time
because is is like with the amount of
artists that we have especially in
Atlanta like you just have to stay on
top because I mean right now everybody's
hungry out here so like everyone's
trying to copy everybody out we're not
trying to copy everybody but you know we
have some people trying to copy us but
is is what it is and you know I
understand because everybody's just
trying to get it out here but you know
they come at a time when you had to be
just original because I mean you can
copy us for a little bit but you know
we're we're always like we know
everybody what everybody's doing
somewhere like are you doing this and
we're gonna do this and we're gonna do
this so we throw you off with this and
then you know it it's just a game it's
just fun it's fun to us that's why we
like to have fun with it because it's
everyone knows they can't really imagine
like I have everything written down in
this book like I don't know I can't show
you all I hear you but you know the
secrets yeah you know everything is
written down it's just planning like you
say um on the 10 steps you just have to
plan and you know work out you yet and
of course everything isn't gonna work
out but you know you have to learn from
your failures and everything cuz I sure
didn't get it every time there's a lot
of people I hit up that didn't reply
back so you know just keep going go back
yeah we got it going I like it
you know you just always have to take
chances because people like the whole
thing like when I started the music was
people weren't trying to take chances
like people weren't trying to drop music
you know drop videos or anything and
then once me and zamorano came out and
then you know we started dropping the
stuff I was like oh okay we keep oh
we're gonna drop our music now cuz they
drop their music you know just just
trying to follow some you know but um it
is whatever it you know you just got to
follow your heart at the end of the day
because the only person that's gonna
keep you going is yourself and if you
let yourself get to you or you let the
hey get to you is is not gonna end well
and I've seen it and and pretty bad for
some people I like I like the fun theme
I feel like you need to have fun song or
something that the next track it might
be in the words sneak peak what's your
favorite top ten video man favorite top
ten almost it would have to be it would
have to be Drake's alright nice I'm
Canadian just the same city man I like
Drake it's just the way that he ties
like I feel like I feel like we had the
same like mentality towards things and
you know cuz he's a businessman too and
I just like the way that he maneuvers
cuz you know I mean he's at the top
right now shout out to Canada
he's really putting on for it for you
guys so you know I'm proud of him for
that I love it
cool well let's get to some questions if
you guys have a question for Z no you
can leave it up in the chat there and
we'll get through them first one
sensation I wants to know how did you
guys start out in your business so I
mean I can do it on my side but you go
first how did you start out say you know
what's the story alright so basically I
started out I was bored all right this
is this for my production side not my
singing side for my production side
since I've been doing producing for more
than I've been singing really I started
out I was bored in my room one day back
then we had the iPod Touch so I was just
on there I was on the app store I was
looking for different apps and then um I
came across this app called fo studio
and you can make beats on there so my I
I'm gonna get this app and then I
started messing with it just fooling
around on my it's actually pretty fun
and I saw myself like doing more and
more and more beats just on the iPod I'm
like my beats are sounding pretty good
just on the iPod touch because you know
I didn't have an iPhone back then so um
then I'm just like all right well let me
see how the professionals are are doing
this and then I I was searching online
and I found everybody was using FL
Studio I'm like okay I've used FL Studio
in my iPod Touch I might as well get it
on my computer and see what I can do on
there so you know I got it on there and
things haven't been the same ever since
I've just been working on that and my
singing
actually my singing side I actually just
started seeing like last year around
like November because really um I've
always been singing but I don't know I
didn't really want to break out as a
singer because I wasn't really like I
was scared of what people would have
thought of me but then you know I was
just like you know whatever like I don't
care and um we had dropped the morning
the morning song and really I found out
like once I became an artist like I
started getting a lot a lot of exposure
cuz I used to produce beats for people
and you know I got a little exposure
from that but that was basically their
exposure and then once I came out with
my own songs people are like okay he's
actually pretty dope I'm gonna listen to
him so I don't know I'm just getting
more recognition as an artist right now
so I'm just like you know i'ma keep
pushing at this cuz I can do the beats
and the singer I love it that that
moment you know where you decided to
push through the fear right like I'm
gonna I want to be a singer I want to
try this out but you know I'm a little
worried people they might think of me
you know it's not the greatest thing a
lot of people never make it through that
fear right they're just worried about
the judgement and so what what kind of
message if you have to those guys who
they're letting fear hold them back
really own fear I'm gonna keep
fear is gonna hold you back is gonna it
there's not one person wear it fear
doesn't come into this so you're gonna
you're gonna get the fear just know that
and just take action you have to take
action that's there's no way around it
if you don't take action you let the
fear win and you just played yourself so
so that's that's really all to that
you've had to take action I love it for
me it was I didn't want to live with
regret I kind of looked like hey what's
everyone going to look like when he's
you know 90 years old and on his
deathbed and I don't want to look back
in my life and regret that I didn't yeah
right they say that's the biggest regret
they are they say that's the biggest
thing that people on their deathbed hat
is just regrets like I could've did this
or I could do that for me
I don't know about everybody else but
I'm not trying to have that because if I
if I'm gonna do something I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna push and I'ma get it by any
meat so okay Sean is next how do you
turn something you love and this
something that can pay the bills okay
work first what you have to do is you
have to list out every everything that
you know right now on on ways where you
think can generate the most money
because if you if you can write them
down on the spot then that's more than
likely your way of doing it and then
after that you can look you start
looking at ways and then um just start
researching different ways that people
are doing it and then create your own
ways like are they're doing this so I
can create my own revenue through this
or I mean it really does is it for the
like the music or for like I didn't
specify just said how to turn something
you love into something that can pay the
bills oh okay cuz I mean if you're a
music producer then I mean really are
your artists really it shows nowadays
nowadays is is the show's cuz um went
down like music downloads people aren't
really paying for music anymore so
really where we get our money is the
shows in merchandise and endorsements
yeah I think it's also important to like
you gotta love what you're doing right
you got to love the process
like someone knows loves it that's
another thing don't love it just because
I love it I mean you can do everybody
has something that they're really good
at you just have to find what that is
and you'll be the best idea yeah I mean
if Xena was getting the music just
trying to make money it wouldn't take
off like he's I love the singing love
the beats love the production for the
love it like I said we we have fun in
the studio like this is easy yeah you
have to enjoy the process and and when
you do then your talent starts to get
better I I remember listening to Eminem
doing an interview and he would do he
liked to crank call into shows I mean
and he is one of his mentor's grew up
was LL and he called in the ll LL Cool J
on a on a radio show and he's like hey
ll man I'm a big fan and he called
himself like Adam from Miami or
something let me let me rap for you man
let me rock for you and you know and the
song right and then so he started
rapping and and I was like man you're
pretty good like you need to get a
contract or something bro you're really
like that's some boy I think I think I
saw that scene that yeah and so like so
didn't know was Eminem actually calling
in but the talent was obvious right
because he had because the dude worked
his ass off right like Eminem worked and
worked and worked and practiced and
loved what he was doing and in the
talent became obvious and so you know
you wanna make money from from your
talent you got a harness that talent
pour some passionate love into it so
that when people see you doing your
thing it's obvious that you are really
good at it I love that clip and I love
alive I think it's the only audio I
haven't seen a video of it but I would
love to see like LL it's actually Eminem
calling in alright next up the next shot
wants to know what's your favorite color
favorite colors they know my favorite
color is actually pink and you why pink
and no not the regular ping is hot pink
hot pink all right is right why is it
pink I'm just like have you seen the
color pink
pink is popping like on anything hot
pink is just popping like you can't help
but to notice it it's like neon
I'm loving the passion for hot pink man
I don't know if I've ever heard anybody
more passionate about a color then right
there correctly like I can't come on you
got to own it
I gotta go orange it's on my branding
you know got the orange I'm gonna winch
guy orange pops - man orange is not the
standard cuddle orange pops in that it
does may not pop like hot pink but but
it's got it's got some pop to it I don't
know I like I feel like I don't like
orange as much as you like hot pink
though that that's some that's a mad
love see that's a problem right there
you go I mean I'm gonna love the orange
that much Shawn is asking I love the end
stressful intro song a top ten would be
awesome they want a top 10 intro song
bro top 10 uh actually give me some
ideas for that I was actually thinking
about something for that yesterday and
today I was thinking maybe if I was
thinking if I should sing with no beat
or if I should have a beat and make like
actual like like another like five
minutes on I mean five seconds song
there's something like that I mean this
is whatever but that's definitely in the
works
alright I'm excited by it yeah I mean
when I listen to morning obviously
morning to wake up in the morning ties
well to the in special theme the top
tens come out at 8:00 at night more of
an evening thing kind of give you some
extra energy to get through the night
give you some try to watch every single
one I've watched I watched a lot that's
a lot of top tens man yeah I've watched
every single one - yeah so if you guys
have ideas for what you want in the top
ten intro song put in the comments and
we'll check it out ray
asking I think this is all you men do
you use waves
what da W do you use I don't diagnose
that means man I got you because I know
what that means
all right so the D aw I used FL Studio
and I used to use Ableton to record but
then I sold my laptop so I I went back
to fo soo because Ableton is more for
like Apple and then Ethel studios more
for like Windows or whatever and it was
the other own you gotta break it down
for me what's da W I still don't even
know um digital audio workstation and
that we like what you you like the
software that you use to create stuff
okay so the question is do you use waves
and what da W do use okay are you yes I
use waves and waves I use waves for um
for vocals which I mean you already know
that whoever was asking but um for the
Beast I don't really use waves for beats
I don't know why I just I just like it
for vocals because it just makes your
vocals pop it's just pop pop pop pop I
just love I don't know it just it does
color it just colors your voice and um
for beats I use iZotope to master it and
to give it that uh that flow so and you
can look that up you like things that
pop I think that's gonna be another song
to man pop yeah yeah I'm trying to break
into the pop industry do you already are
your everything man you're all the
industries in one it has the pop right
Bailey you can't go into our music like
all right i'ma just them let me see what
they're doing you got to go in there was
a happy mood like alright let's see what
they're doing this time try to you have
to try this on it like what do they do
it this side but I like it man
sensation I I can't
I always can't figure out how to get the
email of entrepreneurs like Evan what do
you do to reach out to get my emails and
other people's emails alright what you
have to do you have you have to be
stealth you had to be stealthy way
you have to go in really the easiest way
would probably be going on something
that they're not really big on and then
see if they posted any other information
on that because obviously if they're big
on let's say like YouTube or something
obviously they're probably not going to
hit you it because a lot of people have
already tried to hit them up and they
get a whole lot messages and it's I mean
the odds of you getting picked out of
other messages is it just Slim's down so
definitely find something that they're
not big on and then finesse your way
through that and then get the email and
in the email make it make it look
professional to the extent that you want
to just make it something I appealing
that they'll want to reply to otherwise
they'll just be like oh there's another
person that's just trying it we
chocolate me you gotta make an email pop
and pop everything like I get a ton of
emails I respond to people but I
remember getting your email like man
this guy like one he's watched the
videos he knows what it's all about like
he knows the morning series he has a
song called morning like there was it
was obvious that it wasn't just some
spam email that you sent to a thousand
people that it was kind of customized
for me your friend at the channel you
love the videos like that makes it a lot
easier to open it up and want to respond
back so I think people kind of mail it
in a little bit too much they just do
the same email copy/paste 100 different
people's m2 that's another thing don't
spam people because if people see like
five messages from you they're gonna be
like alright I'm not trying to respond
to you so I already know that just gets
hectic okay we're already bumping up
against a clock but let's go let's go
for one more
all over ramped 9 well I hope it got
that okay 15 years old wants to be a
singer worried about people you know
doesn't believe in in him or her
what advice do you have for 15 year old
once it gets started in the industry
alright basically um the first thing you
have to do is believe in yourself and
yes there is believe in yourself I can't
I can't stress that enough once you
believe in yourself then you can get it
and then along the way you're gonna get
haters like I have a whole lot I have a
whole lot of haters I'm not saying that
just know like it gets real out here is
scary it's scary I'm gonna keep it
really scary out here but you got a
maneuver and just surround yourself
around people who who believe and
actually surround yourself around other
artists and stuff like that and work
with them and then you know um get in
the circle and you know fine really
all you have to do is just find out
what's like how you can record on the
best equipment because really everything
is just about quality if you have the
best quality people are gonna choose
that over something that sounds like you
recorded it on a iPod touch but I mean
that's that's just how it is out here
people want to hear quality I love it
cool well man we're little bit over I
really appreciate the time thank you
guys all for watching you have
Zeno's info is in the description we put
a link up to his soundcloud that's the
best place to reach you Xena yes and I'm
also Instagram I don't have a Twitter I
mean I do have a Twitter but I don't I
don't really post a lot of good stuff on
there but my Instagram is poppin its
poppin everything is poppin I feel like
I'm poppin after this I like it you just
watch it and eat just energized us your
bass it's as a no bounce huh there we go
I love it man thanks for the time thank
you guys to watch and continue to grow
leave and we'll see you soon